Hello, Dr. Kevin Cutters again here just sharing some of your most frequently asked questions.
Here's one.
What do I do when I get other testing done?
Maybe you get it done at your functional medicine doctor locally.
Maybe you got it done at your oncologist.
Maybe you had your natural path out of the street do a lab or something like that.
So we're talking about testing that you got done that we did in order that our clinic did
in order.
You got something done.
You had an exam, let's say at your oncologist office, you met with a surgeon, something
like that.
And they gave you information.
So you have labs, you have CT scans, you have PET scans, MRIs, some other data that you
want to share with us.
This is where it goes, send it to labs, L-A-B-S, at cuttersclinic.com, labs at cuttersclinic.com.
That comes to us.
It comes in an email so that we can then put that, please put it in a PDF form, if at all possible.
And then in that PDF that we can upload it into your file.
So that's how we get it into your file.
Now understand when you send us a lab or data or something that you had done or if you
have a concern with that, the impetus is on you to contact us.
So you're just sending us your information that is done in an outside source.
So we're not going to make an assumption that you want to talk about it.
So when we look at that email, that's going to be taken care of by an employee of mine.
So they're not going to connect with you.
If you want to go over that data in any way possible, we're happy to do so.
Contact our office, call the clinic and make an appointment with myself or Michelle or your
L-A-Zone.
If you just need to talk about it, if there's something you don't understand, many times
we understand other practitioners don't have the time or they're just not set up in a
way to really explain a lab or a test to you.
They might just kind of cursly go over, well, it's worse we need to do this or it's better
we need to do this and you just maybe you want some understanding about it, we're happy to
do that.
Understand there's going to be a fee for that for you to spend time with us to do that.
So we're happy to do that to explain to the best of our knowledge what that data that
you're setting us means.
So just understand you'll just pay per visit and per 15 minutes slot like any other visit
you would have to pay for.
But we're here to go over your concerns.
If the test is better and you want to celebrate, call us and celebrate and that's great.
We'd love to hear from you.
If it's worse and you need some concern, you need some understanding or we need to ask
to be retested.
This is a good time to maybe do a cheek swab.
This is a good time to maybe tweak your frequencies.
Do everything that we can do our part, which has to do with your nutrition and your diet
and your frequencies or anything that we can recommend on our part.
Or if you just need some help to go over whether you should do keyboard things, we're always
happy to talk to you, but you have to call and make that appointment.
I can't read your mind.
So don't ask me to do that.
So don't get mad at me if we didn't contact you.
We're here for you to reach out.
We're here five days a week.
You can call and make an appointment.
So we're here for you to talk about things.
We're here for you to bounce ideas off.
This is what my oncologist said.
What do you think about that?
We're here to retest you.
We're here to tweak some things on our side and mostly we're here to pray for you and
pray with you.
So we want to be that support in that way for you as best as we possibly can.
So utilize us, we're your friend, we're your companion, we're not your dictator.
So we're your coach to help guide you, we're not your boss.
So that's the difference in our clinic and some of the other clinics out there.
So utilize us in that way and we will have a great relationship.
No no matter what you do, we'll be praying for you in all things.
Remember that's labs at colorsclidic.com, labs at colorsclidic.com.
Thank you very much.